[音楽]
夏休みが終わる某すぐついに本格的に大学始まってしまいます
肇社長です第てくるんだぜすや長いんですけども条約
僕の大学もそろそろ勝ちスタートで既に卒業論文を書かなくちゃいけなくて
ちょっとその準備とかでバタバタしてるわけですよ
大変な時期でございますはいそんな人のことをどうこう言ってる場合ではない僕なん
ですけども
今日はリクエストも多く my mommy からも何も言ってやりなさいと言う
8 o ガーディまぁ僕も同士なら話そうかなと思って久しぶりちょっと勉強の話を
しようと思います学生の方が多いと思います誘い皆さんに今僕がどのように大学受験の
ときに勉強をしていたという道教を話そうと思いますあの子の話を聞くまず前提として
僕は頭が良くありません
バカです勉強も嫌いですメーカーグハ
地面頭ええみたいなことを様に言われるんですけども僕はを見ては取る
まあ天才と製材どうかつですね返済だぞ体裁だけども返済と勉強ができる頭狩りコン
ピューン違うせバボカ掲載だけど nsa だけども僕は決して頭がよくない
ただなんやかんやうまくいってるんでいわゆる天才ってやつかもしれないしね
キラーあっあっそういう話じゃないけどそういう話
ないんですけど僕は頭がよくないですでしてバダの部位ですね中学校の時の英語の成績
一番低い時100点中16銭とかほぼ学年ビリだった時も結構あったし本当に基本見る
勉強嫌いの全くしなくてそんなみなさんが思っているような僕は何か
すごい人間つありますねまずそのことを離さが張って勉強がだ言って泣きたくないよ
ゲームしたいし遊んでたいし皆さんの質問力あるのは勉強するやる気が出ません
そもそもやる気ないもう飽きられてるみたいな人が多いんですけれどもそれはみんな
同じだそうって事なんて言いたいですね俺から寄せてみるとで勉強が好きとか言ってる
奴ちょっとここを歌う
がいやそんなことはまあ勉強し
する気が無い方の人間ですまずそのことを分かっておいて僕の話を聞いてもらいたいと
いうことで始め社長の受験勉強法
5つの後東京話そうと思いますあとまで僕のやり方ですから皆さんに合うかどうかは
分かりません僕はこれでまあなんとか何とか間に合った感じです
じゃポイントその1時間をかけましょう勉強にねこれもう当たり前ですよ
シーガーなら勉強方法と塾に行ったり効率は良い勉強方法あると思うんですけども俺
たちば彼はこれ tv 落ちても時間かけないと結局戦績は伸びないなんにしてもソ
結局時間かけないと意味がないのでとりあえず時間をしっかり取りましょう今日勉強
やる気しねえって思ってる時点でもう遅いですよ考える暇だったら指を動かしましょう
バカの実測でスポンとに歌い的
な目標は気にしない扇な目標を立てるな可能ですねやっぱり受験勉強というのは他の人
と戦うわけだし大きな目標があるわけですよこの大学に行きたいとかここに行きたい
先生から列車放射能のプレッシャーようなことだねこう心を首絞めることになりかね
ないんです
僕はそもそもそんな期待されてなかったんか別に変なプレッシャーじゃなかったんです
けどもうあまりね大きな目標を立てるとそこに向かっている過程でずっ鯉心が苦しく
なる時があります辛いと思うよ本当に見えない氷に走っている感じがねすっごい僕が
苦手だったんで俺は大きなポットを記した紙を使って考えたらもう疲れちゃうんでれて
体を動かして勉強すれば ok です
不安になるくらいなら考えない方がいい僕はその考え方でまあ最後の方結構ジムシィと
か出たんですけどもあまりこれがつべにならずに勉強できた方だと思いますで3つ目
勉強する時間ですこれはとても大事ですよ
勉強するためには出る時間が必要ですねないと後は回転しないんで勉強してもその覚え
られなくなります絶対に出ましょうねえちゃんとそのねっ
いる時間は勉強ができないので管理ねどんなさん見て寝るかあとまたに向けて勉強する
かというのは非常に大事になってきます僕はね実験期間中夜の10時22時に出てまし
た絶対に12時に練って次の朝の4時に起きます6時間睡眠といえばまあ頭を回復する
と思ったのでば最長頭が回転しないから4時半過去 a time 塗って手法して
ましたね家
確実によりより早起きの技術な前早起きがいいかというとしたの脳味噌っていうのは何
か起きてから覚醒するのに約3時間ぐらい時間がかかるって聞いたことがありますそれ
で4時に起きるとだいたい朝の7時にはモードにとか覚醒してモダン回転する状態に
なります学校始まるから8時半からだったって
学校柱二巻ではのび太振り返って授業の全部散らす頭に入りやすくなっているという
状態でございますそれが星だよ夜中遅くまで勉強して朝の7時とかに起きると雨着覚醒
完全に回転する時間は朝の10時の授業が始まっちゃってますつまりその授業中に先生
が言ったり勉強したことは能見さに効率よく入れないような状態になっているという
わけで僕そんな脳科学的な方がよくわからない
ですけども授業の時間学校に行く時間を無駄にしないためにも早起きはとても良かった
んですね4つめこれはちょっと人によって違うと思うんですけど友達とつるまない学校
で楽しくすると基づいたんですけども基本的に一人コードですね止まらず嫌いだったと
なったわけじゃなかったんですけど
勉強は僕ひとりであるものだと思っています
友達てやっててもいいんですけどもなんかそのなり愛してる時間が僕はもったいないっ
て言って一人でも突っ走りたかった何も気にせずでもったいねーじゃん喋ってる時間と
か友達に聞いて時間たら自分で勉強するわって話でそっか勉強で助け合いとかは全くし
ない人でした一人だんされると職安に行って一人で夜遅くまで図書館で勉強して一人で
分からないことがあったら調べて友だちはシャッ
ダート全部一人の世界に入って随分とずっと戦ってましただけだったからもう下から
はい上がるためには時間がなかった理由は本当に頑張ろうと思ったら買ったそういう
友達とかんとね勉強するのは僕はいらないかなって思ってましたでも一人じゃ良かった
けどストイックに成田市
おかげさんの政治ていても気にしてなかったですよ友達と成績を張り合ってて急に
流れるとするとやる気
いけなくなったりする一匹狼で頑張ってました勉強はその後これがたぶんねもう付んし
てなくても勉強しなきゃいけないみんなに言えることなんですけども気持ちの問題です
受験はもうメンタルが物を言います
まあ僕日々の勉強は全然やってなかった人なんですよ
ベーシックブーツも出さなかったしレイキテストそんな昼食は良くなかったんですけど
唯一僕の中に持っているの中様部活動で身についたかせないんですよ持続力続ける力
途中注力とやる気かこの3つで付踊りきっていうのはもんですそして頭がいいわけでは
ありません根性だけはありますよ今度時はありますしてそのやっぱり限定な辛いんです
よ私立に行っちゃうとすごい
お金がかかるんでなるべきシリーズには行きたくないなって言って者と妻のプライドも
あったしいろんなねその要素があって僕もやっぱ不安でしたらんだったんですけど
そんなの気にしてると何も始まらないぞというわけで僕はもう一つだった方が勉強して
いたわけでございますなんかどうかで同じこと言ったな結果というよりなんだその理由
がわかって勉強とかいうつまんねー事に行く
2時間をかけてどれだけ必死に向き合いて頑張れたかというそのがまた自分がいい
大事なんだと思います僕の中で奪った友達でもその勉強で追い詰められてちょっとずつ
チックになっちゃった友達もいました
女友だちもいたんであんまゐこ髪が勉強しろ勉強症って言う
うわけにもいかないというただ僕は粘りました
一人で全部やりますとは言いつつ家族の支えとかもちょっとあったし勉強は楽しく
なかったけどそうだったんだろう
頑張っている自分でちょっと酔いしれてたかちょっとダッジな受験勉強の僕なりの
ポイントみたいなことを話してみました
まあ受験勉強だけじゃなくて普段の勉強にも役立つことが言えたのかなと思います
何度も言うけど僕は球がよくないし馬鹿ですバカなりにもすべての時間を全て勉強に
通して何も考えずにただがむしゃらに勉強すると中学校の中で1位とかに慣れたなって
いうのはして全国的に見ると全然さんの頭いいわけじゃないんですけども俺はダメだ私
ダメだっていう子がたまにいるんでそんなことないですよ
センター試験の当日も朝から始まります
voodoo 3
ブーブーブーブードゥ
ます
しています